[Music]
one of them is a place a secret place
where nothing is impossible no way
miraculous place where you could
actually change the world hi I'm Mike
Zimmer from FX guide com4 wired Brad
Bird the director of The Incredibles and
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
returns with his view of the future in
Tomorrowland and as the name suggests we
visit a future world and to convey the
wonder or and spectacle of its
optimistic future bird takes us on a
six-minute long continuous shot
revealing Tomorrowland fire a curious
magical pin bringing in that world to
life and realizing his vision was up to
Industrial Light and Magic in San
Francisco in the end we splitted it out
into about like seven or eight shots
each of those shots at about three or
four plates and everything was kind of
time together so we go from like this
continuous like flow through
Tomorrowland where we start from like
the beginning of the city we get into a
monorail and end up like in the
spaceport where our hero like is just
about to board a spaceship and
eventually like the pin runs out of time
the sequence took almost 10 months to
stitch and composite together with 12
artists working at various levels due to
the complexity of aligning all the
various plates some shot in Spain some
in Vancouver or without motion control
and all needing to be integrated with
the magical world and futuristic tech
that ILM could come up with if you get a
chance see the film in Dolby vision this
is the first film to be released in the
new format and as such Tomorrowland has
a wider dynamic range for example when
the Gateway opens to the beach the film
holds and balances the vastly different
exposures between the interior of
Tomorrowland and the bright daylight of
the tropical beach island was the first
studio to have to deal with Dolby vision
which provides more than just increased
contrast range I can see like this
technology changing the way compositing
will be done in the next year like you
know because we're gonna have to first
have maybe monitors that can display
those values we have like now a 4k HDR
in
a material to give you a thing about the
dolby vision is that by the extract
contrast it provides gives this kind of
extra sharpness and looking forward will
have even more from ILM as we hit summer
blockbuster season so don't forget
subscribe for more behind the scenes
action I'm Mike simul for wide
[Music]